mitochondria are organelles found in
eukaryotic cells that play an important
role in the production of ATP the
universal energy currency used in all
cells most mitochondrial proteins are
transported from the cytosol into
mitochondria through specialized protein
translocator complexes interactions
between these complexes bring the outer
and inner mitochondrial membranes into
close proximity the successful targeting
of many proteins that reside in the
intermembrane space requires
translocator complexes that cross both
the outer and inner membranes after
entering the inner membrane translocator
many of these proteins do not completely
cross the membrane but instead are
released into the membrane and diffuse
laterally they then remain embedded in
the inner membrane or are cleaved
releasing a portion into the inter
membrane space
very few resident proteins are simply
transported across the outer membrane
translocator complex matrix proteins do
not transit through the inter membrane
space but are directly transported from
the cytoplasm across the interacting
outer and inner membrane trans locators
[Music]
the protein-rich matrix contains enzymes
necessary for cellular respiration a
process during which carbon fuel
molecules are oxidized and reduced
electron carriers are produced
invaginations of the inner membrane
called cristae contained four large
protein complexes that harvest electrons
from these carriers
complex-2 accepts pairs of electrons
from succinate and transfers them
through a series of redox centers to
coenzyme q the lipid soluble coenzyme q
is reduced by electrons harvested from
complexes 1 and 2 and then diffuses
through the inner membrane transferring
its electrons to complex 3 in complex 3
electrons are transferred through two
distinct series of redox centers which
allow them to cross the inner membrane
one at a time
finally electrons are accepted by
cytochrome C which carries them to
complex 4 where they are transferred
through another series of redox centers
to their final acceptor a molecule of
oxygen that combines with hydrogen ions
to form water electron transport in
complexes 2 3 & 4 is coupled with the
pumping of protons from the matrix to
the intermembrane space the resulting
electrochemical gradient across the
inner membrane is called the proton
motive force protons flow back into the
matrix through a component of the ATP
synthase called f0 the membrane embedded
ring structure of f0 binds protons in
the intermembrane space and releases
them on the other side of the inner
membrane into the matrix proton flow
drives the rotation of the ring
structure which in turn leads to the
rotation of the fzerocentral shaft
the rotating shaft sequentially contacts
the three catalytic subunits of the ATP
synthase f1 complex altering the
subunits affinity for ATP and ADP and
catalyzing the synthesis and subsequent
release of ATP most of the ATP
synthesized in the mitochondrial matrix
is consumed outside of the mitochondria
but the inner membrane is impermeable to
ATP and ADP therefore an ATP ADB carrier
is responsible for the coordinated
import of adp and export of ATP across
the inner membrane in cells mitochondria
are distributed near sites where ATP and
other mitochondrial metabolites are in
high demand
marek Andreea move alongside of skeletal
structures such as microtubules and can
undergo dynamic changes in shape
including both fusion with other
mitochondria and division perturbations
in the dynamic behavior of mitochondria
and alterations in mitochondrial
membrane permeability are associated
with the early stages of programmed cell
death
[Music]
[Music]
you